dominique paturel bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous je suis au plaisir
parmi ces palmiers fait une température
estivale fait que c'est très agréable
que vous avez une façon d'accueillir qui
est exquise tafer chaude voilà un peu là
non alors en disant votre carrière j'ai
presque envie d une saine lecture déjà
oui tout à fait j'ai presque envie de
vous dire il était une fois la star
non comment sont pas comme ça parce que
non les bouteilles cette femme n'a rien
à voir oui maintenant mais j'ai beaucoup
travaillé qu'est ce que vous voulez
c'est pas de ma faute j'ai été un
tâcheron du spectacle j'ai fait
énormément de choses mais je crois que
c'est pas du tout à ce niveau là non
j'ai eu en fait la chance que ça marche
pas mal et puis de faire plein de choses
et puis de mener en même temps des
carrière au théâtre à la télévision et
c'est donc en effet une liste
impressionnante mais ça c'est ce que je
crois pas vous savez non c'est parce que
je suis un comédien qui a bien travaillé
j'essaye de faire un survol bref salon
survolons si je me trompe vous m'arrêtez
hossa je suis sûr que voilà
alors votre carrière elle démarre à
l'école du spectacle de la rue blanche
la rue blanche oui oui bien sûr comme
tous les talents vous être refusé
vous permet d'entrer très vite au
théâtre hébertot ça a été tout de suite
ça a été très curieux parce que la rue
blanche je sais moi je suis arrivé dans
ce dans ce métier ne sachant pas du tout
ce que je venais y faire puisque j'avais
aucune idée de ce que c'était quatre
comédiens j'avais envie date celle de la
vocation une vocation à l'état pur le
stress d'appel comme ça irrésistible tu
seras comédiens monfils et comme j'avais
des parents merveilleux et adorable
la première stupéfaction passé ils m'ont
dit mais après tout pourquoi pas c'est
une très bonne idée l'essentiel c'est
que fait pas un raté c'est le seul
conseil que m'a donné mon père qui se
trouvait était très bon et puis je suis
parti comme ça avec ma petite valise en
carton
et je suis arrivé à l'école du spectacle
parce que j'avais trouvé ça dans un
magazine féminin bien connu il y avait
un reportage sur l'école du spectacle
est une école d'état de la rue blanche
alors je vais me présenter à ce concours
c'est un concours d'entrée il y avait
350 postulants et 11 élus et il se
trouve que j'étais dans l'es11 j'ai pas
encore très bien compris pourquoi alors
je suis resté rue blanche à peine six
mois parallèlement j'ai déjà commencé
j'étais engagé à faire des tournées déjà
pendant que j'étais à l'école c'est vous
dire que j'ai été marqué par le destin
pas de aucune chance d'y échapper et
alors on m'a dit présente-toi
conservatoire alors j'ai passé le
premier tour impeccable très bien je
veux dire le deuxième tour pas de
problème et le troisième tour paf et
quand j'ai dit mais pourquoi on m'a dit
on trouve que vous êtes prêt à jouer que
vous avez rien à faire au conservatoire
je me demande encore si c'est un
compliment une vacherie m'enfin m'ont
invité je me suis très dehors
absolument à ce que c'est une chose
qu'on n'oublie pas parce que ça c'est de
l'horreur c'est l'horreur un petit jury
comme ça dans le noir on entend une
petite cloche suivant ces failles en
faut déjà rentrés sur cette scène du
théâtre du conservatoire qui est fort
belle d'ailleurs nos fins et quand on
arrive de sa province en sachant pas
j'avais un costume que j'avais emprunté
un copain parce que j'avais voulu faire
propre quand même
fait quelques frais faut bien dire et
non mais c'est vrai que c'est cesser des
épreuves et pour l'âme mais ceci dit il
ya une chose qui sauve quand on a 20 ans
ou à peine c'est l'inconscience il
faudrait que je refasse ça maintenant
j'aurai un infarctus l'hôpital avec des
tubes partout parce que c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable
m'enfin là on se rend pas compte moi je
me rendais pas compte du tout donc ce
refus sur refus du conservatoire j'ai
tout de suite pensé à des tas de gens
comme jouvet comme tout ça je me suis
dit je suis pas le seul j'ai dit c'est
peut-être un signe c'est bon et puis
j'étais prêt à refaire ma petite valise
en carton pour rentrer dans ma province
et j'ai téléphoné à mes pauvres parents
disant voilà vous voyez ça n'a pas duré
longtemps à peine une petite année et je
rentre à la maison et et puis le
lendemain matin il y avait un
pneumatique soumah sous la porte de ma
belle chambre de bonne
me disant de venir auditionné au théâtre
hébertot et le lendemain du jour j'ai
été recalée au conservatoire s'était
engagé au théâtre hébertot pour y jouer
les classiques etc et ça a été le début
d'une longue longue carrière voyez vous
chers amis très vite interrompue très
vite interrompue oui relativement daru à
un moment où on a eu des petits
problèmes comme ça alors fallait bien
faire le soldat quoi et comme
j'avais pris un sursis
bêtement
je suis arrivé au bout de mon sursis
c'était l'algérie direct alors que si
j'étais parti avec ma classe j'aurais
fait 15 ans de service militaire et
j'aurais pas été rappelé et c'est que je
suis quand même d'eau et quoi ya pas de
doute quelque chose
alors là ça a été 30 - algérie mais je
veux dire que ça a été une période
formidable parce qu'il ya tout tout tout
tout événement comporte un un positif
car je pensais c'était un peu le
désespoir je suis ça y est c'est foutu
une interruption pareil
à part jouer gabin dans la légion que je
veux vraiment c'était bon et puis
finalement les événements se sont
arrangés mais là ça serait l'objet d'un
d'un une histoire en cas de tome parce
que c'est énorme on fait à des histoires
bon c'est eu toute une aventure mais qui
fait que réquisitionné par l'armée je me
suis trouvée d'avoir speaker d'antenne à
la radio
belge été réquisitionnés on m'a dit vous
maintenant plus de sortie et j'ai été
escorté angie par des parents en emmener
à la radio parce qu'on avait vus sur ma
fiche comédien est alors je me suis tous
les bulletins de la bulletin météo le
quai c'est ce moment là c'était un
speaker qui faisait le journal parlé
alors je faisais tous les journaux
parlés depuis 6 heures du matin les
cours de la bourse parce qu'il n'y avait
qu'un speaker d'antenne c'était bon et
alors là vous savez c'était les speakers
à l'époque aujourd'hui 14 mai le conseil
des ministres s'est réuni voyez fallait
faire bloc dans le joli quoi alors les
cours de la bourse la météo tout où nous
passons la parole à notre correspondant
à tizi ouzou enfin voilà alors et puis
un beau jour on est venu me trouver dans
mon spi de mon petit vie dans mon petit
studio de speaker puis on m'a dit voilà
il ya pierre dux qui doit venir jouer
les vignes du seigneur mais pour la
télévision mais y'a pas d'avion est ce
que vous pouvez jouer ça je dis mais
c'est pour quand hamdullah c'est pour
dans quatre jours
oui elle c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé à la télévision en direct bien
sûr les vignes du seigneur le rôle du
steinby albert ne s'est levé avec madame
béatrice brethes i qui avait créé la
pièce web prêt et je verrai ça a été à
la fois la plus belle des trouille de ma
vie en même tant pis alors là ça s'est
un peu enchaîné alors à chaque fois que
on pouvait me faisait faire une
dramatique des qui revient comédien qui
avait un peu pas très envie de venir à
alger parce qu'ils avaient peur de pas
en repartir en venait me chercher à la
caserne l'engin le sait de garde à la
kasbah où quelque part me disais voilà
la brochure vous donner ça lundi elle
vendredi soir en direct ont joué les
dramatiques j'ai joué plein de
dramatique comme ça alors je prenais en
montant la garde dans la journée je
venais répéter je faisais l'émission en
direct et le lendemain j'étais appelé au
bureau du colonel dans mon émission
comme hier soir rien et bien
le jour il va pas de trouver bien je
vais jouer en
même temps bon j'ai fait plein de choses
j'ai fait des spectacles pour mes
camarades dans le plein et partout on a
monté des coups fumants phase a été une
période assez finalement assez riche et
il s'est trouvé que quand j'ai été
démobilisé au bout de 30 mois
de cette vie militaire et télévision de
radios et de tout ça je faisais des
émissions enfantines faisait la
vaisselle le ménage soit fait j'ai tout
fait mais j'ai appris mon métier d'une
façon unique faut bien dire que j'ai
rencontré des tas de gens merveilleux et
formidable quoi parce qu'on a fait des
choses superbes et puis après alors
qu'il avait été content de mes services
ce qui fait quand j'ai été civile à
peine j'étais rentré chez moi j'ai reçu
un télégramme on faisait revenir
comme faisait revenir pour faire des
trucs et je suis retourné vers une
émission superbe pour le vendredi saint
une émission en direct c'était la
passion
d'un homme et à rocourt qui est un
superbe passion tout ce qu'il ya de
classique et de traditionnels qui
passait en direct le vendredi saint il y
avait plein de scènes en direct en
studio mais on avait trois semaines de
tournage tous les extérieurs et tout ça
qui était dans des décors somptueux
parce qu'on attendait le golgotha
dans les endroits où duvivier avait
tourné golgotha en est on est dans un
superbe jardin des oliviers et c'est ce
qui fait que j'ai quand même été à la
fois le christ voyez ce que c'est pas
donné à tout le monde c'est une
expérience quand même
c'était c'était maintenant mais ceci dit
c'était très beau mais à ce moment là
j'avais pratiquement l'âge du rôle donc
ça l'est évidemment maintenant on
n'imagine pas que je pouvais faire ça
mais c'était bien tu es un souvenir
formidable ah oui alors j'ai fait plein
de trucs puis je suis retourné faire un
autre film après et puis après bombe à
une fois rentrer à paris la fed us 4 les
autres trucs quoi alors là j'ai
recommencé à travailler j'ai fait une
bise armand j'ai fait une comédie
musicale
non je chantais du chantier et bien
dansez maintenant que c'est fait c'était
comédie musicale absolument superbe ça
s'appelait cloche de mon coeur et
c'était l'histoire d'une espèce de bande
de clochards comme ça qu'ils vivaient
sous les ponts il y avait une dame du
monde qui voulait absolument connaître
l'avis des clochards et tout ça il y
avait tout un petit univers comme ça y'a
et charles moulin qui était le berger
dans la femme du boulanger voyage et
avec du bon moment et oui et alors
c'était des musiques de l'ihf herman qui
a écrit beaucoup de chansons pour mon
temps et je jouais un personnage un
petit peu ambigu parce que ma chanson
d'entrée quand je rentre en scène
c'était je suis à voilà voilà voile et à
vapeur ales hemsky situe quand même les
personnages et alors on s'apercevait à
la fin de la pièce qu'il faisait ça
juste pour s'amuser tromper l'ennemi
qu'en fait il n'était pas du tout comme
ça puisse qui finissait sa fille sait
très bien se marier avec une charmante
jeune fille avec qui nous avions
quelques duos et cette charmante jeune
fille c'était une débutante
qui faisait ses premiers pas sur scène
deux comédiennes qui avait d'une voix
superbe superbe et qui a été très très
doué pour la comédie à mon avis je suis
très surpris qu'on l'ait pas employer
plus souvent comme comédien elle
s'appelle nicole croisille
voyez vous alors de la date une bien
vieille amitié et c'est un souvenir à
chaque fois qu'on se rend compte le club
de mon coeur qu'on a chanté ensemble
c'est toujours une grosse partie de
souvenirs très très pittoresque à nicole
croisille et quand même c'est dans la
chanson mais vous non
significative
il ya tellement de comédiens qui chante
et chanteur qui joue la comédie que moi
je suis kardec nos soldats un seul côté
parce que là c'est reparti j'ai refait
du théâtre après j'ai joué
oui plein mais par rapport au théâtre
classique est toujours une petite
connotation un peu péjoratif samedi va
non ça dépend des boulevards comme
disait je ne sais plus qui s'appelle
théâtre de boulevard parce que les
théâtres qui sans qui s'appelle comme ça
sont situés sur des boulevards
[Rires]
non c'est juste
faut quand même pas tout confondre non
c'est à dire que moi au boulevard j ai
joué du guitry je veux qu'on peut
appeler ça du théâtre de boulevard si on
veut la première pièce que j'ai joueurs
entrants d'algérie c'était mon père
avait raison donc si vous voulez qui est
une superbe pièce avec une distribution
et valentine tessier landrel hughes et
il y avait marre idem s'il y avait enfin
plein de gens superbe et je dois dire
que bon c'était un spectacle
magnifique vraiment et puis après ça
j'ai joué au divertit et puis j'ai joué
de chekhov mais ça dans des théâtres de
boulevard puis j'ai joué beaucoup de
classiques parce que je suis entre eux
tnp comme vous le savez puisque je vous
hais voilà alors bon mais c'est vrai que
j'ai joué beaucoup de pièces classiques
je crois que si vous le si je fais un
équilibre doit pas y avoir beaucoup plus
de pièces de boulevard qu de pied dit de
boulevard entre guillemets fin de pièce
moderne disons que de pièces classiques
y en a à peu près autant parce que j'ai
fait beaucoup beaucoup de classiques
c'est vrai est ce qu'il ya un rôle qui
vous a particulièrement marqué ou
au théâtre
ils m'ont tous marqués ils ont tous
marqué j'espère qu'ils ont marqué aussi
le public
est là quand la fatigue non mais y en a
plein parce que moi j'ai eu la chance de
jouer des rôles formidable j'ai été très
gâté
c'est vrai que
j'ai joué des bons ils affrontent un
turcaret que j'ai joué au tnp dans une
mise en scène de villa avec une musique
de duke ellington qui était venu
enregistrer la musique au théâtre à tous
avec ses musiciens enfin cd souvenir
formidable et puis bon bah figaro j'ai
joué chez chez barrault suis resté cinq
ans figaro du mariage fait garant du
barbier cdc les chefs-d'oeuvre à l'état
pur je dirais que quand on se glisse
dans un rôle comme ça est ce qu'on
essaye de de savoir comment on joue elle
et les autres comédiens et concours
comment s'adaptent non moi je moi je
j'essaye de pas à chaque fois que j'ai
eu un rôle que je j'espérais jouer j'ai
pas voulu aller voir mes camarades non
pas par prétention mais pour pas me me
donner un impact négatif si vous voulez
parce que c'est vrai que quand on
attaque des des personnages comme ça on
a toujours peur de la comparaison il ya
des grands aînés qui ont laissé des
traces illustre sur ses rôles et je
trouve que c'est pas femmes en ce qui me
concerne parce que je suis un peu trop
sensibiliser mais je veux dire que je
n'ai pas eu envie d'aller voir parce que
je me suis dit j'irai les voir après ou
rouge bon mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu paniquant parce qu'on se dit de
toute façon on se dit il faut que je
fasse autre chose et je ne veux pas tu
influencer ni dans un sens ni dans
l'autre et puis et puis chacun après
tous ensemble j'aurais pu rien vous
savez on pourrait plus jouer après
gérard philipe on pourrait plus jouer
après mais on pourrait plus jouer je
veux dire qu'il faut bien plonger un
moment à l'autre si on était pièce soit
jouée quand vous étiez avec villa vous
avez
et vécu au festival d'avignon absolument
c'était quoi c'était superbe c'était
dans la grande cour des du palais des
papes parce qu'à l'époque n'avait pas le
off eloïne
le choix de ce mode là il n'y avait pas
de 178 spectacle à l'heure et gavet
joignant mais ça veut dire que
maintenant il sait très bien il ya une
animation fantastique il ya des
spectacles partout c'est vrai et c'est
très bien ben je sais pas peut-être que
c'est trop si c'est peut-être un peu
trop hein je sais pas je m'en rends pas
bien compte mais j'ai peur que ça soit
il ya ça se télescopent un petit peu
j'aime patients puis les gens savent
plus très bien ce qu'ils vont voir enfin
bon à l'époque il y avait juste là la
cour des papes c'était vraiment et puis
le tnp qui jouait là enfin je veux dire
et on n'y a créé une pièce superbe qui
s'appelait la halle 4 2 à la mea
et qui s'est créé dans la cour du palais
des pâtes à une histoire qu'ils veulent
on répétait dans la cour du palais des
papes et alors vous savez on essaie de
canaliser un peu les visites du palais
des papes pour pas déranger la
répétition alors les gens attendaient à
la porte d'entrée quand on répétait
l'après-midi et puis dès qu'on faisait
une pause ou quelque chose il y avait le
guide qui emmenait les gens est alors
bien sûr on était en train de répéter
l'a42 à la mea il y avait un brave guide
du palais des papes avec un accent comme
inimitable et il ya une dame qui dit
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que
c'est qu'ils parlent pas du coin
et le guide qui avait plus ou moins bien
entendu le titre c'est celle escalade de
l'himalaya est la bonne seul but mais de
quelle hauteur et dans les 8000 la 1963
vous passez dans une troupe tout aussi
célèbre ci doit être absolument voila
voila j'ai eu la chance d'être engagé là
il m'avait vu
dans toutes les choses que j'avais fait
à la télévision à ce moment là le fameux
chevalier de maison rouge etc et il m'a
engagé pour jouer shakespeare je suis
rentré là pour joueur lent d'autres
comme il vous plaira et puis à la suite
de ça j'y suis resté cinq ans nous nous
sommes sortis que avec les événements de
mai 68 on nous a demandé gentiment de
quitter les lieux tout ça c était occupé
on pouvait pas rester quoi il y avait
trop de monde dans théâtre de l'odéon à
l'époque des faits il foule considérable
il y avait plus de place pour le théâtre
alors on s'est retrouvés un peu à la rue
quoi mais là j'ai eu cinq ans il bonheur
cinq ans de bonheur parce que des
spectacles merveilleux des créations du
théâtre moderne et du tas de classique
puis détournés comme avec vilar
d'ailleurs des grandes tournées à
l'étranger à l'époque les grandes
troupes on se promenait dans le monde
entier avec villarreal au mexique en
argentine
moscou la pologne la roumanie la
bulgarie
l'allemagne l'autriche et cetera avec
barwell à l'italie avec bar où on a fait
à nouveau la roumanie l'autriche
l'allemagne
la l'angleterre le tape des nations en
angleterre on a fait enfin des tournées
avec du théâtre français dans des
conditions uniques pour approcher des
pays parce que bien sûr reçu parce que
des visites exceptionnelles nous
montrant des choses que le le touriste
ordinaire n'a pas toujours l'occasion de
voir je veux dire et puis rencontrant
des tas de gens passionnants des
écrivains des peintres des auteurs des
parce qu'on nous met en contact bien sûr
les réceptions des choses sont
organisées avec quand même toute une une
l'intelligentia comme ça artistique de
ces pays traversés et je vais axer
fantastique parce qu'à l'époque moi je
me souviens je ne sais pas comment c'est
maintenant mais à l'époque le
l'entousiasme pour les spectacles est
une chose qu'on ne soupçonne pas les
spectacles en français moi j'ai joué des
pièces pas facile comme le faiseur de
balzac pour une pièce tellement connue
bon quand on joue la barre déjà ils
connaissent mieux mais quand on joue moi
j'y ai joué l'équipe de jd des auteurs
comme pas évident
même turcaret lesage c'est pas un
classique très très connus jeudi déjà en
france c'est limite mais bon c'est ce
dois dire que les réactions des gens
aussi bien moscou qu'en pologne que par
tous et à la à la virgule près ils
réagissent non seulement aussi bien mais
presque mieux qu'en france alors bon
c'est des souvenirs sublime parce que
c'est à la fin du spectacle 35 minutes
de rappels
35 minutes de rappels saluer
et se dire les salle debout et nous
lâche en plus je veux dire c'est on
n'imagine pas ça en france doit presque
regretter le retour en france non mais
c'est c'est fabuleux puis un tel
engouement pour le théâtre français au
mexique c'était pareil on est resté
trois semaines à mexico en jouant quatre
spectacles soient différents c'est
peut-être complètement
la folie les gens se battent tout est
loué six mois à l'avancé il ya il ya des
queues énorme d'or pour six adhérents du
ou des gens malades qui viennent pas
enfin c'est les places se vendent au
marché noir enfin c'est
oui puis on imagine plus ces choses là
on a l'impression que ça n'existe
maintenant je crois que ça n'existe que
pour les galas drogue pour les trucs
comme ça je veux dire c'est vrai on bon
c'est que quand michael jackson fait une
tournée ou un truc comme ça c'est ce
genre de phénomène mais moi j'ai connu
ça pour le théâtre alors en 68 vous quel
théâtre sortie un peu vers les
barricades vous savez ce que c'est oui
et puis bon on va peut-être aborder les
abordons le passage de télévision
je laisse
ma pauvre âme et un des leurs il a fait
tant de gens savent où koné
baky koné les feuilletons ça me connaît
il y en a eu plein je ne citerai que
pour mémoire pour moi
bien sûr l'impérissable est
indéboulonnable comme dit l'autre
chevalier de maison rouge qui a été un
tournant décisif de ma carrière c'est
vrai que je lui dois énormément même au
théâtre même partout ça a été une espèce
comme ça de deux rôles fétiches qui m'a
vraiment propulsé qui m'a vraiment
propulsé dans des tas de direction et
dont je bénéficie encore parce que je
dois dire que presque trente ans après
35 ans après 30 32 ans après m'en parle
encore
alors ce qui est même étonnant parce que
je crois que c'est un phénomène un peu
il ya eu des grands feuilletons de
l'époque thierry la fronde et cetera bon
belphégor qui repassait c'est à dire que
cette époque là tous les feuilletons de
cette époque là les gens s'en
souviennent c'est fou parce qu'on en
parle encore donc c'était quand même
quelque part à ces événements quoi je
lis un bon après j'ai tourné le bonheur
conjugal j'ai tourné le grand pote de la
bérézina j'ai tourné
lagardère j'ai tourné
d'artagnan bien sûr les toute la série
des d'artagnan j'ai tourné le dernier
feuilleton de la rtf et le premier en
vidéo qui s'appelait recherches dans
l'intérêt des familles qui étaient une
espèce de deux séries policières
amusante et aux clins d'oeil comme ça
qu'on était deux de flics aux petits
pieds avec mon ami michel roux voyez
tout de suite le style un peu comme ça
humour de la chose et en attendait ça
six mois comme ça puis j'ai fait encore
puis j'en ai fait encore là et les
indiens qui s'appelle l'hôtel du siècle
et puis j'en ai fait enfin bon départ
mais et puis les films des dramatiques
car non et puis surtout surtout c'est
que j'ai connu ma l'époque bénie des
dramatiques en direct c'est à dire
toutes les grandes dramatique en direct
dramatique
dommage rcd période on a toujours
l'impression d'un peu de faire faire des
souvenirs d'ancien combattant quand on
parle de ça entre nous c'est presque
notre guerre de 14 à nous parce qu'on a
l'impression que ça remonte à la nuit
des temps et que la télévision marché à
la bougie à l'époque mais en fait c'est
quand même pas si vieux que ça et c'est
vrai que les émissions dramatiques en
direct y'avait l'espèce de
l'intensité du théâtre c'était vraiment
quand on entende l annonce de la
speakerine la régie nous dit attention
annonce qui crée une fan speakerine on
attendait le klaxon
le rouge et je dois dire que nos
camarades cadreur les gens qui étaient
au câble les gens du sud de la lumière
tout le monde était s'était brusquement
une une espèce d' équipe soudée on se
disait il y en a pour deux heures et
quart faut arriver au bout yele c'était
fabuleux parce que aussi bien en régie
avait une tension il y avait une espèce
de 2,2 comme ça on jouait tous le même
jeu en même temps et il n'était pas
question de se planter il n'était pas
question d'arrêter on pouvait pas
interrompu pouvoir lancer on pourrait
pas bon et je veux dire que c'est vrai
que la télévision et je crois que c'est
pas les téléspectateurs qui me
démentiront il ya eu à cette époque là
des émissions donc là aussi les
spectateurs regardent encore la
nostalgie c'est vrai ça m'est arrivé
d'avoir des trous dans cet
enregistrement d'avant départ les pas de
ces gens là on vous ment jamais vous
plaisantez c'est là on entre on n'en
dormais pas parce qu on en rêvait la
nuit parce que le cauchemar du comédien
c'est le trou
bref quelquefois la nuit qu'on rentre en
scène pour jouer une pièce qu'on n'a
jamais apprise c'est l'angoissé la sueur
froide et aux non heureusement qu'il y
avait pas de trou oui bien sûr même
encore que ça se voie pas
d'avoir un incident quelconque et là je
me liquéfie
non mais non mais la télévision vous
savez cet été c'était une époque bénie
on peut parler un peu de télévision
maintenant on attend non parce que si on
n'a pas le temps mais c'est vrai que
l'épée moi j'étais en touche fermé tout
le temps
comme disait l'autre l'explosion de
l'audiovisuel pourvu que ça ne pète pas
la figure
non mais je crois que si vous les voyez
moi je vois ça un petit peu là mon à mon
point de vue parce que chacun voit midi
à sa porte quand je faisais de la
télévision il y avait une chaîne donc il
y avait déjà cette chose formidable pour
nous les acteurs c'est qu'on était sûr
d'être vu
c'est vrai il y avait pas de choix c'est
pour ça que maison rouge
tout le monde l'a vu parce qu'il n'y
avait qu'une seule chaîne c'était le
feuilleton du samedi soir et qu'il ya eu
que quatre épisodes contrairement les
gens aient l'impression que ça durait
deux ans en fait il ya quatre épisodes
d'une heure oui non mais je dire bon et
ça a eu un impact parce que c'est un
sujet parce que vont mes
donc on vous voyait déjà bon puis on
s'est dit bêtement qu'on va y avoir deux
chaînes de travail le travail va être de
multiplier par deux quand on nous a
parlé de la transe est dit là c'est
génial parce que on va avoir trois fois
plus de travail puis quand est arrivée
la quatrième chaîne on s'est dit alors
là c'est quatre fois plus de trains et
bizarrement il ya quatre fois moins de
travail parce que je ne sais pas à quoi
ça tire je ne suis pas un économiste et
je ne suis pas un financier mais je
pense dans ma petite tête comme ça tout
bêtement je me dis qu'au fond le volume
la masse d'argent qui peut être investi
dans des productions et dans des choses
ne bougent pas tellement
elle s'est morcelé au lieu d'être
regroupés sur une seule chaîne ce qui
fait que chaque chaîne à mon avis à un
petit peu moins de moyens si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire je crois que je ne
sais pas si c'est une bonne explication
mais moi les ailes et simple est me
direz vous il ya certainement devant
leurs récepteurs des spécialistes qui
doit faire ouaf ouaf ouaf mais je veux
dire je sais pas c'est peut-être pas
d'explication en tout cas moi je je je
constate par contre je parle
sérieusement et c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'on fait beaucoup moins de télévision
qu'avant quand il y avait un message à
bah oui quand il y avait une seule
chaîne un kolkhoze le début de la
deuxième c'était pas encore possible
c'est vrai qu'on faisait je pars pas
seulement moi je parle de tous mes
camarades de ma génération les plus
jeunes ou les plus vieux on faisait à
peu près
4 dramatique par an est en tout cas un
feuilleton par an est-ce que vous ne
souffrez pas un peu d'être remplacés par
des séries mais alors on va y arriver je
savais que les alliés m'amener là parce
que évidemment
alors justement on en arrive au
phénomène suivant c'est que le volume de
productions c'est vrai que maintenant ça
coûte cher de produire c'est vrai que de
faire une dramatique en costume ou et
cetera et cetera c'est vrai que c'est
très cher ni fameux charge la masse
salariale machin ben may moralité les
chaînes maintenant font quoi parce que
c'est moins cher on prend des séries
étrangères des séries américaines j'ai
peur qu'avec l'explosion de
l'audiovisuel comme on dit et comme vous
le disait si justement avec ces chaînes
qui nous arrive là rapidement qu'est ce
qui va se passer on va avoir des jeux
parce que ça coûte pas trop cher et puis
on va voir des séries américaines
brésilienne italienne etc en veux tu en
voilà qu'est ce qui va se passer les
comédiens au lieu de faire de la
création où les réalisateurs ou les
décorateurs ou parce que les auteurs
parce qu'il ya quand même bien pas on
pense toujours aux acteurs parce que
c'est ce qu'on voit sur l'écran mais à
tout le monde derrière je veux dire
qu'ici il ya toute une volume de
créations et de gens de créateurs qui
sont concernés et moi je suis je trouve
ça un petit peu inquiétant parce que
c'est vrai que ce sera les jeux les
séries alors on en arrivera à quoi ce
que les comédiens en tout cas feront du
du jeu du doublage voilà bonjour dallas
non recommandés je veux dire que alors
c'est vrai que maintenant les gens vont
passer leur temps moi je vois déjà
maintenant l'ailé les changements c'est
que l'actuel mans il ya des maisons qui
utilisent si plateau par jour de 9
heures à 24 heures ou 3 heures du matin
tous les jours pour doubler parce que
faut fournir la parlez nous un peu du
doublage puisque effectivement vous
doubler cet inénarrable 0 et double
dallas est un secret pour personne je
coin jean double d'autres aussi qui
n'ont fait beaucoup moins de bruit j'ai
doublé plein de séries dont personne n'a
jamais parlé parce que ça n'a pas eu
cette espèce
comment ça se passe et bien alors en
attendant on peut en parler
on a un écran on a un écran sur lequel
est projeté le film en version originale
quelle que soit sa langue si c'est un
film allemand japonais anglais et
rustique aux slovaques ou suédois est en
dessous vous avez un deuxième écran sur
lequel défilent une ce qu'on appelle une
bande rythmo c'est à dire une pellicule
sur laquelle est inscrite le texte
français il y à un repère sur cette
bande est à chaque fois que le mot
attaque leur père si vous lisez pile oh
non ça passe vous êtes synchrone
synchrone avec l'acteur qui cause sur le
bon alors la difficulté je ne vous le
fais pas dire si qu' il faut pas avoir
l'air de lire qu'il faut jouer il faut
avoir un oeil sur l'acteur qui est sur
l'écran un oeil sur la bande qui est en
bas un autre oeil pour surveiller la
fafo tout faire en même temps donc ça
suppose du réflexe ça suppose faut
dominer la technique il faut là comment
dirais-je il faut l'avoir complètement
assimilé pour jongler avec ne plus avoir
de problèmes techniques et ne penser
qu'à jouer la situation hélas ou
heureusement la qualité intellectuelle
de dialogue
vous travaillez pas tous et non c'est à
dire que la tension non mais quand vous
doublez non non bien sûr là on parle de
séries américaines mais il faut savoir
aussi que le
le doublage s'adresse aussi aux films
bon alors quand vous doubler par exemple
dernier fellini ou quand vous doublez
l'ailé bergman ou quand vous doublez le
dire que là c'est un bonheur sans pareil
parce que d'abord vous avez souvent des
acteurs absolument fabuleux sur l'écran
et que vous avez là aussi un dialogue un
texte costaud je veux dire que là c'est
quand même moi je trouve que la
profession en tout cas au niveau des les
réalisateurs français ont un peu
tendance souvent je parle des
réalisateurs de cinéma à baver sur le
doublage en disant c'est une horreur
c'est effrayant moi je suis désolé on
peut pas faire autrement alors rappelons
c'est un mal nécessaire mais c'est moi
je vois mal la france avec des films en
version originale par tous bon il ya une
élite
spécialisés qui comprend les langues
étrangères qui aiment le cinéma avant
mais la majorité du public ne va pas au
cinéma je pense que les sous titres est
une chose que les gens assimilent assez
mal bon et puis en plus à la télévision
je vois pas les séries américaines ou
brésilienne en version originale c'est
impensable
donc il faut bien les doubles et plus va
y en avoir plus il va falloir les
doubler moi c'est ça qui j'ai peur que
maintenant devienne un pays où on fera
du doublage bon dominique paturel anémie
science se termine bien on était bien on
était bien commencé à bronzer moins bon
en un mot en amour à pignons avait comme
projet eh bien écoutez vous allez vous
allez pas tout à fait me quitter déjà je
pense que ça va vous faire plaisir je le
savais non parce que là il ya des choses
qui sont faites et qui ne sont pas
encore passés je viens d'avoir eu la
joie de travailler avec vos voisins
jeudi la joie parce que moi j'aime bien
je le dis tout bas comme ça j'aime bien
les régions parce qu'on y travaille dans
de bonnes conditions c'est par le stress
de de la sfp ou des grosses maisons
comme ça énorme et je viens de
travailler avec vos voisins défaire
trois lions un très beau sujet une
émission qui fait partie d'une série que
réalise chaque écrit frédéric pautz cher
vous savez le chroniqueur judiciaire sur
les grandes affaires du siècle je viens
d'être le personnage
cléden d'une aventure d'un fait divers
authentique défrayé la chronique qui
s'appelle la mala goût fait la malle
sanglante de lyon alors on attendait ça
et faire trois lions et ça n'est pas
encore sorti ça sortira sur fr3 je crois
dans le courant de l'année il y à une
autre série qui s'appelle des toques et
des étoiles qui n'est pas encore sortie
réalisée par roger pigaut que sur la
cuisine ne pas le temps d'aborder ce
sujet mais enfin j'avais une recette à
vous donner mais tant pis
on choisit ont choisi et puis enfin il
ya comme ça parce que plusieurs choses
qui sont
qui sont fait qu'ils ne sont pas encore
sortis et que je pense qu'ils vont qui
vont être diffusés dans les semaines et
les mois à venir les spectateurs sont
ravis de goûter moi je suis bien content
d'être venu ici c'est de besançon est
une ville superbe parce qu'on est à
besançon là j'ai pas et vous croient
peut-être qu'on est ailleurs on peut
dire qu'on était un petit c'est superbe
la station est magnifique c'est un décor
de rêve c'est vrai je présente pas là
non c'est vrai c'est très beau cet
endroit et je connaissais pas la ville
de besançon c'est une ville absolument
fascinant mais l'arrêté vous reviendra
voilà je reviendrai c'est promis merci
de me laisser moi
[Musique]